this man's been added so long that when
America's Funniest Home Videos which
he's the current host of debuted he
already had a few years under his belt
on the show silver spoons and was part
of the Fresh Prince of bel-air and now
he is the host of one of the
longest-running shows on television in
his 29th season America's Funniest Home
Videos 7:00 p.m. Eastern on ABC every
single Sunday host Alfonso Ribeiro good
to see you too buddy
sir so now we shared a very warm moment
earlier this hour yack back in the green
room when I found out that you're from
New York City absolutely grew up in the
Bronx okay so that means you're a Yankee
fan yes I am a Yankee fan guy diehard
like mask how old are you I am 47 47 59
right so we lived through the Reggie
Jackson Lee Dave Winfield like the you
know Ron Guidry my my daughter's middle
name is Mattingly really that's how
seriously you were you're okay you win
you also said that you grew up being in
New York yeah a jet fat as a jet fan
growing up as a kid but like you know
back in the day they wouldn't air the
game on TV if it wasn't sold out so you
got blacked out yeah cuz a stadium
didn't it was sold out obviously during
the 70's with the Jets so you I would
want to watch football on TV on Sundays
and eventually like you would just watch
whatever else was on TV yes so a lot of
times that would be the Cowboys and the
Cowboys were winning and so eventually
you're like you know what um that's my
team but I'm gonna like them too right
and then eventually it became I like
them only and then the Jets just became
like you know okay you know that's okay
it's a part of my history okay but we're
we we have a lot of work to do in in big
date like we have uh we have a lot of
work I think you know look I've been
I've been a die-hard for now a very long
time many many decades we won't go into
how many of the decades but as a few yes
um it's time that the owner gives the
job of GM to someone who really really
knows what he's doing and to allow our
team to get a coach that has
true identity right I feel like
America's Team no longer has an identity
it's just kind of Middle America wash
kind of no real definitive direction in
terms of the way the offense works I
mean are we a running team are we a
passing team obviously you know our old
line is is kind of in shambles right now
even though cuz that's how they built it
but I just feel like Garrett doesn't he
don't do anything like he doesn't have a
true coaching style identity and I think
the Cowboys really need that in terms of
the owner being the general manager and
giving up that role that what's the
words for it isn't happening we know
that we we do on on earth one yes which
we co happen to do we do we put a lot of
time honor those people yes
that is not happening well you know then
then he's gotta recognize that turn it
into a business and not and not a fun
thing for him to have right like the
relationships that he has obviously you
know Garrett was his you know felt like
his child right and it was like he but
he's not the heir apparent right he's
not that guy and I don't see it that way
and you know look we were all fans and
you know I'm not in the game of football
and and never claimed to be and never
will be right um but I just feel like
they need a true identity in terms of
who they are and and I don't feel like
Jason Garrett gives him it she could
give him that that's for sure he could
but then hit people in the eye and it
defensively they're hitting people in
the mouth yes
five weeks like there's a loose money
that has surprised me they are physical
they're gonna hurt you absolutely know
that going into a week against the
Dallas Cowboys I don't recall the last
time I could say something like that
it's been it's been allowed it's been a
long time it's been it's been I don't
think it's been in the last three
decades their identity it could be but I
feel like we're certainly not fully
there yet right to where you know you're
gonna really rest on that defense to win
you games I mean obviously the last game
that's what Garrett did and we lost you
know like he didn't go
fourth he rested on the defense and at
the in OT it didn't work out right and I
get it but like Zeke is great Zeke you
know he's pounding it and he's doing a
fantastic job but I don't see I don't
see them you know stepping out and being
a great team the way we are currently
constructed and I really feel like Tony
Romo played a bigger role in in Dax
growth I feel like how do you mean well
I feel like he was really helping
helping him with Reed's and
understanding how to make in-game
adjustments his his knowledge of the
game and okay I feel like we kind of see
that on CBS when he's you know as a
commentator he really kind of
understands what's about to happen and
the and the plays that that should be
run I feel like that on the sidelines
for dak has been lost and his ability to
make in-game adjustments it's not
happening you're saying Cooper rush does
not offer that from the to number two
hole on that I'm not seeing it it's an
interesting analysis of what's going on
with the Dallas Cowboys and now you're
fired up I imagine of LeBron coming to
town so you're a Laker fan from all the
years of you living out here and living
out here I didn't really watch
basketball as a kid when I was in New
York so I didn't really get into it
until I moved out here and if you're
gonna move out here you know the Lakers
were Showtime it's definitely the 80s it
was amazing you know know a lot of the
guys and you're a kid working on these
shows right and you were going to the
old forum absolutely yeah I would go to
the forum I was really really good
friends with dr. Jerry Buss and we would
sit up in his box as a young man and
hung out with him and the family and
still friends with Jeanie buss and and
so a huge you know lover of our Laker
squad and and I get how a lot of Kobe
fans were losing their minds you know
like you can't have the enemy come but I
think it's ridiculous this is ridiculous
ridiculous look you know this is the NBA
and players change teams okay and
there are very few homegrown stars
anymore okay we're not gonna have the
kid growing up in Englewood who's now
going to be the number one basketball
player in the NBA playing for the Lakers
we're gonna have to go out and get other
players by the way Wilt Chamberlain
didn't play with us his whole career a
Kareem abdul-jabbar didn't play with us
Shire and Shaq didn't play with us the
entire time so let's get over that we've
got the greatest player on the planet
Earth playing for the Lakers now let's
let's get behind them we've got a great
young squad I feel like magic and
palinka did a great job of bringing in
this season some players that can teach
the young squad how to kind of get it
done and also be a contender I don't
think the Lakers are winning the
championship this year but once we get
that next max player I think we have a
shot alfonso ribeiro I'm glad you have
that attitude because when I heard Laker
fans out here saying LeBron coming here
infringing on Kobe's turf go he's gone
it's like cry me a river over a having
generational talent and a generational
talent show up here either via
acquisition he's left a free agency cry
me a river I would take LeBron James in
a Knicks uniform even though I've sworn
off that team can despise the owner and
I understand be kidding me absolutely
and even if la Bron in his three plus
one deal that he's given the Lakers here
even if he lets just let's give him half
of those years of championship let's
just do that right which is maybe never
no he's still way behind Kobe in the
amount of rings and in terms of what
he's done else it's just you it's you
can't even compete well the problem is
is that the logic is counterproductive
right so we don't want the best player
in LA because we don't want to win any
more championships and rest on Kobe's
wins right doesn't that make absolutely
no sense at all let's instead let's just
see if lavars right yes let's see if
lavars right about this kid it doesn't
make any sense like if you want to win
go out and get the best players possible
LeBron is the best player on planet
Earth
I'm gonna go with LeBron on my team and
and root for him versus let's root for
some other guy because I want to
remember
Berko be Kobe's not picking up a
basketball he's not putting it through a
hoop again Laker fans let's get past it
let's move on to the LeBron era and
let's love it let's love it we've got a
great team and Magic is doing a
fantastic job I just I by the way I just
feel like you're sitting on the set of
America's Funniest Home Videos which is
a great show and you do a great job of
it deep down you want to pop off about
the Laker fans you want to pop off about
the Cowboys and you know I feel like
you're getting this opportunity and I
gotta get out to the world like come on
y'all right now let's get down to it
here what is your handicap right now I'm
a two handicap
two handicap the lowest I've ever been I
was a plus two at one point you're on
strokes to the course was giving strokes
to the course you're like wow here's
this course I'm gonna hand it back to
you I don't need don't worry I'll get it
I'll get it back from you
no but III love this game I'm actually
an ambassador for the PGA Tour champions
and so it for me this game brings me
happiness on a daily basis I mean
whether it's actually playing thinking
about it I wake up every morning and I
think about the game of golf
I practice three things in the shower
every morning oh my god my putting
stroke and my chipping I don't really
get that serious cuz you slip and fall
and bust your butt but but just the
technique and the feel of it
because like I would say the ball always
just simply gets in the way of the club
you're not hitting a ball the ball is in
the way of your of your swing so if your
swing is solid the ball just gets in the
way and goes where it's supposed to go
see interesting I would love to just
don't think I don't have you know golf
makes me happy for various reasons okay
cuz I'd like being outside right I like
just being able to tap out a little bit
although my friends always rag on me for
having my phone a little bit too handy
all right
me man okay you got a lot going on I do
so but you know I love the camaraderie
of it mm-hmm
but so much else if it frustrates the
hell out of me I wish I could just say I
pick Dolph makes me so happy you know
what what I you know so I actually coach
my wife right and most guys would
typically be like there's no way does
that work I'm going down that road right
fantastic
it works out great when she started
playing golf she was shooting in the
high 130s within six months she was
shooting in the low 90s and the reality
to me is is that because you have to
start over sometimes right people we
hold on to our past a lot as human
beings you have to decide do I want to
be better or do I want to be mediocre
right now and not get worse to get
better you have to get worse you've got
to break it all down you've got to start
all over and you got to learn the proper
technique based on your body and your
natural ability you know I see people
all the time want to look at oh I want
to emulate Jason Day swing
you can't emulate Jason days swing Jason
Day is a freak of nature he is an
incredibly powerful limber guy you can't
do it so learn the swing that works for
your body type and your natural ability
so sometimes you got to start all over
to get this so what conversations have
you had with Berkeley well the problem
with Berkeley isn't his body or his
ability its his mind that hitch is
ridiculous and you know but it's
interesting because I have actually been
on the range with Charles and watch him
actually hit great shots on the range
with no hitch at all this is fully in
his head something about on the way down
he has not been able to figure out how
to make whatever that is disappear he's
afraid of contact Charles Barkley is
afraid of he's aren't afraid of contact
have you told this to him eat well
listen we've had plenty of conversation
short yeah I've known Chuck for a long
time yes and and we talk about it all
the time it's like something he's like I
can't
figure out why I'm afraid to like I
can't let it happen yeah like what I
mean what I always say to him
it can't be worse I mean the funniest
thing the funniest Charles Barkley story
was I was playing in Mario love news
golf tournament and it was me Emmitt
Smith and Charles Barkley and I had not
seen Charles Barkley play this was
decades ago okay and Charles Barkley
goes yo we betting I guess what do I
mean I don't we probably shouldn't bet
Charles right I mean I've heard that
you're not very good but like we
probably shouldn't bet he's what we mean
what do you mean no come on let's bet
thousand dollar hole well I was like
whoa Charles I was like charles i i've
known you too long i'm not taking your
money I'm just I'm not taking your money
Charles Charles like come on oh you're
gonna be disrespectful I was like all
right Charles how about it you know what
we'll just low score 18 holes we'll just
do that rather than you know match play
hole by hole use a thousand dollars okay
because I can accept taking a thousand
dollars all you think it's like that I
had not seen the hitch to this point so
he gets over the ball but the first tee
and he starts down and has that like you
know stroke moment and he was like oh
you can be disrespectful disrespectful
you are being disrespectful to the golf
swing right now what are you talking
about and I didn't had the first time
I've ever seen it so clearly it you know
he's shot like 130 and and I shot like
74 and was like I guess I'll take my
grand now I didn't want to take your
money Charles you know it's true you
know it's true I've been able to double
the amount of money you earn if you beat
him by 60 strokes I beat you by more
than fifty you pay me two grand we
haven't even talked about your show as
Funniest Home Videos 29th season yes
yeah it's you know I feel so fortunate
and lucky that I get to to be the host
of the
show you no institution it is and to be
part of that kind of legacy and to you
know for me as a family guy love my kids
or sitting with my kids love hanging
with my kids yeah
my wife and I will sit there and watch
the show on Sunday nights and even
better sometimes when I'm working on the
videos I have to do the voice-over for
the videos yes sir they'll send it to me
in advance and so I'll sit in front of
the computer and both my boys will sit
on my lap and we'll all laugh together
as we go over it and it just it's just
it's as you know what better world than
being able to enjoy what you do with
your family right and and for me it just
it's it's such a blessing I really do
feel like you know I hit the jackpot
You certainly have sir and I want you to
come back because we haven't hit on
pretty much a ton of stuff that I'd love
to lose and you know I'm well I mean
well hey hey with the tissue what that
mean no I mean I mean listen go your red
socks listen okay all right I see where
you at
there's nothing else tonight when I come
back you know Houston's gonna beat up
with y'all anyway currently in its 29th
season
29th season America's Funniest Home
Videos Sunday at 7 p.m. eastern time on
ABC great to see you sir last Alfonso
Ribeiro Alfonso underscore Ribeiro on
Twitter to follow this man the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience